on Prime crime he was going to go to
play with his friend and um he didn't
come back The Disappearance of an
11-year-old boy the whole Community came
out in full force everyone wanted to
find this boy turns into a devastating
Tale full of lies and betrayal the guy
was in there he had one of the guns I
was terrified so terrified the
investigators started to see that
something didn't quite fit here
something was
[Music]
off hey there everybody I'm Jesse Weber
and welcome to Prime crime where we
break down some of the most compelling
and memorable True Crime cases in our
next story about The Disappearance of a
young Colorado boy you need to hang on
because this story goes in all different
kinds of confusing and chilling
directions 911 my son was supposed to be
home at 6:00 and was almost 7 he's only
11 okay what's his name
Jon it's January 27th 2020 Colorado
Springs Colorado 36-year-old Leticia
Stout who's married to husband Albert
Stout is calling to report that her
stepson 11-year-old Ganon has gone
missing one of you
maybe around like 3:30 maybe has this
ever happened before uh no no
11-year-old children don't just
disappear off the face of the Earth that
automatically put everybody on edge so
we went to the neighbor's house my
daughter just went to see Ray Park and
he's not there and who was the last
person to see him uh I guess me our
assignment desk gets the notific a a
11-year-old boy is missing in this nice
little Community called Lon Ranch there
was a lot of fear there was a lot of
concern of where he could
be hey can we come in hours later police
arrive at the Stout's home to talk to
Leticia her daughter Harley and ganon's
sister Lena while Albert ganon's
biological father is out of town for
work he supposed to be here at 6:00 cuz
we were going to eat dinner and his dad
I already told him he could play with
his friend and um he didn't come back at
6 so we drive to the neighbor's house
and they're like uh no he's not here it
didn't seem like there was enough
urgency in her voice it seemed like she
was not scattering in terms of her
thoughts of what's going on my stepson
is missing it was more like she was
trying to piece it together you have
talked to all of his friends parents my
husband did he's been on the phone with
a bunch of them he's Oklahoma no he said
he's talked to everyone that he knows of
we had heard he went to a friend's house
but all of the community couldn't find
him anywhere at first we had heard
rumors this boy could have been a
runaway the next morning Albert arrives
back home from a training session with
the National Guard he and Leticia meet
with detectives at a coffee shop to gain
some insight on where Ganon could have
gone he told her he was going to play
which they do all the time maybe he's 10
minutes late but you know nothing like
this big deal here is he's a home body
he would rather be home playing his
little Nintendo or you know watching
cartoons so he's not one just to walk
off we're talking about January in the
Colorado Rockies it's cold in fact there
was a pretty heavy snowstorm that
occurred in the days following gan's
disappearance the likelihood that an
11-year-old child without substantial
help from somebody outside the home
could survive during that period of time
greatly diminish the chances that we
were going to find him alive and return
him to his family when was the last time
he talked to his mom his biological
mother he talks to right they talk
almost I say five times a week not to
add any confusion to it but like the
mom's married to a guy that's got a lot
of trouble with the law and that was one
of my first instincts it's worth putting
down but I mean I don't know if it's
anything legit there'd be so many tips
coming into the sheriff's office they
had to have a separate line so many
people thinking they seen him turning
out not to have seen him this boy's
disappearance was gaining not only
Statewide attention but quickly
worldwide Nationwide online social media
and there was just so much mystery so
much curiosity so much
concern then the day after Ganon
disappeared Leticia tells an
investigator she has something to share
so initially you didn't tell me some
things because Albert was there and
Leticia saying she wasn't able to speak
speak freely while Al was around comes
into the police station to talk once
more but this time she says she wants to
tell officials what really happened take
me through Sunday into Monday and be as
detailed as possible Sunday gon had
started a candle the fire thing went off
it started saying fire fire fire fire so
then I see smoke coming up from the
downstairs so then I ran back downstairs
to get G there's this story that kept
being brought up about a candle what we
heard was that he was maybe playing with
his Nintendo switch by a candle and
maybe he shouldn't have been on his
switch and that his stepmother came
downstairs and he got scared and knock
this candle over the fire was on the
floor over here then on the sof there
was covers everywhere I take a whole
bunch of them and I go and like
basically Smash down on the sofa in the
fire to put it out honestly we were
going to fix the carpet and try to like
not say anything Albert freaks out about
every little thing so that's where
Sunday kind of like stopped and
everybody went to bed but as Leticia
gets to the day of ganon's disappearance
her story couldn't be more different
than what she originally told police as
now she says someone else was involved
and I know there's two things I got to
fix number one I need to fix the carpet
and number two I need to figure out does
Gana need to go get like some burn cream
or whatever L Ranch is a bunch of new
builds like
construction so I pulled up and I was
like hey do you know where you can get
the carpet that is in the lon Ranch
model home so we got the carpet from the
guy in the construction area well I
didn't get it then he said he was going
to bring it to me so I gave him the
address this is where I messed up I gave
him our code to get in cuz he was going
to go fix it and me and Ganon left we
went some places around town initially
we had heard he had left to go to a
friend's house and didn't come back then
after days and no one finding any trace
of that ever happening there was news
stories that someone came in the house
we started to head home as we got inside
I heard something and I just started
walking downstairs open the storage
closet and he was standing in there and
he had on gloves he had one of the guns
and I was terrifi
so terrified and then he just knocked me
down and he was hitting on me he was
trying to like rap me just all my fault
cuz I gave him our code to fix the
carpet okay and I shouldn't have this is
where we hear the story of her being
attacked that someone broke into the
home attacked her and attacked Ganon and
then took Ganon and here's another layer
to a different story that she's now
providing investigators I swear to God I
don't know what happened from there
I really don't know I kind of like
blacked out just a little bit
investigators begin looking into what
Leticia is telling them but in order to
do that they need to examine Leticia
herself for evidence something that
appears to get her agitated we had
talked earlier about whether or not it
would be able to take action at this
point as far as like Gathering evidence
whether it had been too long and I told
you that it wasn't is that something
that you're willing to do yes definitely
I would do anything for you to figure
out who edguardo is we'd like to get you
over to the hospital for that I I would
totally do that but I really am I just
want to get some some food and take a
minute and I can drive myself to the
hospital the investigator started to see
that something didn't quite fit here
something was off okay you said I was
free to go are you wanting to leave
right now I'm really hungry I'm thirsty
my look at my lips they're chaed can you
give me just a few minutes she said that
that I would be able to go and I'm not
saying that you can't I'm asking if you
can give me a few minutes as all I can
if you can you just call me or I have to
maintain my my my mental my mental
health in this whole situation
investigators need to work quickly to
find Ganon but now they aren't sure what
to believe coming up the search for
Ganon Stout
intensifies Ganon comes in to like jump
on him gon was aware that someone was
was trying to harm me that was when he
had the gun to gon everything from then
is a
[Music]
blur hey everybody we're going to get
back to the stal episode of prime crime
in a minute but I wanted to highlight
our partner and sponsor of this video
Morgan and Morgan because as a lawyer I
know one of the most unsettling things
in life is if you get hurt right you
don't know what to do you don't know
where to turn well Morgan and Morgan is
actually the largest injury law firm in
America that's right I mean over 3
million people call them every year they
have completely modernized the process
to make it super easy for their clients
you submit your claim you sign contracts
you upload documents and you talk to
your whole legal Team all on your phone
that's it an attorney is going to review
your case in just eight clicks not to
mention they also have 4,000 support
staff that can help you through the
process too which is just incredible to
think about and in terms of price you
only pay them if you win there's no
upfront fee so if you're injured you can
submit a claim at for the
people.com Prim crime or by dialing
pound law that's pound 529 on your phone
all right let's get back now to the
Leticia Stout
[Music]
case the whole Community came out in
full force we're just trying to find any
clues as to where this boy is if he's
okay if he's in our state if he's in the
country if he's
alive it's January 2020 11-year-old
Ganon Stout has been reported missing
from his El Paso County Colorado Home
ganon's stepmother Leticia Stout
initially reported the boy went to play
at a friend's house and never came home
for dinner but a day later she meets
with investigators and changes the story
saying he had actually been kidnapped
and that she had been sexually assaulted
by a construction worker from a new home
being built nearby then when I get
downstairs he has the gun and he has gon
and then he was like on top of me again
and then I kind of lied out again cuz he
just hid my head but towards the end of
the interview Leticia starts getting
combative when being asked to submit for
a sexual assault
examination it would be better to get
the forensic exam done I'm not going
over there like before you shower not
like clean I'm not doing that that's
disgusting I'm not doing that but I will
gladly go but you realize that's how we
gather evidence right so if you go take
a shower right now and I understand that
you're like uncomfortable I would like
to get you over to the hospital to get
the exam done okay well I then I'm
driving myself there she was transported
to the hospital so that a sexual assault
examination can be conducted but at the
hospital refuses to undergo that sexual
assault examination
she's really trying to set up this idea
and yet she's not willing to give up any
evidence that would help us find that
person sit down on the couch sir I'm I
can't breathe I'm just asking you to
open the door she portrays undergoing a
very severe anxiety attack to try to get
out of the interview now we're going to
have to call you an ambulance because
you said you you got chest pain it's I
just told you I have chest pains it's
claustrophobic I could bre so we're
going to call you an ambulance yeah well
you claustrophobic and until no no I
excuse me I take lorasa pram every day
and if I don't take it I could have a
panic attack that requires them to bring
in paramedics and they find that she's
perfectly normal she knows that the
investigation is starting to zero in on
her Leticia has now told authorities
multiple versions of what happened to
Ganon and rumors about what occurred
begin circling the neighborhood you were
the last person to see him is that right
correct Leticia agrees to speak with a
local reporter saying she wants to clear
everything up but it seems it only
complicates things further what did you
see when you last Saw well I'm not
allowed to talk about anything with the
case I would more so be willing to talk
about how the community needs to have
faith and continue to work together and
not make these false accusations like
the things that have been said that I've
disappeared from the community I haven't
been there to help there was just some
weird things that kind of stood out
based on her demeanor and all of that
you're speaking with someone that is in
the center of the most heartbreaking
situation you could imagine that might
have known some answers and couldn't
tell the public to try to help I've took
care of Ganon for the last two years in
our home because his mother didn't want
to do it and I would never never ever
hurt this child they have all these
theories on how um Ganon is dead he is
not dead we are going to find Ganon and
that's the main goal that we all have my
family has she would always say that she
really loved Ganon and that Ganon was
the favorite stepchild of hers but it's
very clear from the way that she would
treat the kid that in fact he was the
least favorite child in the house Ganon
was by all accounts of Mama's Boy and
that caused Leticia to be jealous of
that relationship that Ganon had with
his biological mother any message for
Ganon Ganon when you get here you'll be
able to truly tell what happened and
then I really hope I get a sincere
apology from everyone we love you and
miss you and we hope that you come home
soon in the middle of that interview
she's talking about Ganon as if he's
going to come home and then she switches
and starts talking about him in the past
tense he was always so helpful with the
dogs around the house he was always like
a person I could say gon can you go do
this and he would do it right away he
was so sweet and such a kind heart that
was a big for us and it it did sort of
put the investigation on a different
track detectives still aren't totally
clear on what happened the day Ganon
disappeared yet they suspect Leticia
might know more than she's letting on at
this point even alout leticia's husband
and ganon's biological father tries to
get answers out of Leticia I'm trying to
do what I can outside of the law
enforcement because you don't freaking
trust them anyways did you trust him not
based on what I've seen so that's why
I'm going straight to the last person
that saw him if I would be the last
person that saw him then I would be the
person that has him Al expresses
concerns that Leticia is holding back
information so he agrees to allow
investigators to record their phone
calls if you know that's an accident are
you going to stand by me yes absolutely
tsha I'm sorry for all the stories I
just didn't know what to do so we were
going to get your look at to get your
bike I was letting get ride it was
really big
so guy was
helping and he fell off it
h she comes up with a story about
looking for a bike to buy for Al and how
she and Ganon had gone up there to look
at the bike she she describes in very
elaborate detail Ganon test riding the
bike crashing hitting his head he was
weding where was he bleeding
from his knees his head there was a
piece of wood with blood on it found in
a remote area uh ways away from the
house that was a huge part of the case
when we found the board up in southern
Douglas County she had to explain why G
's DNA would be found on that board and
what we learned throughout those phone
calls is one the level of lying that she
was willing to undergo to deflect the
investigation away from being pointed at
her but also she was giving us little
Clues throughout where she would
actually include small Snippets of truth
but she would do it in a way that would
explain a way why that truth existed and
why somebody else was responsible for
that
truth I have a phone to call supposed to
be taking him back go 911 so the guy
took him to take him to 911 the
Craigslist guy Quincy brown or
whatever I swear to God Quincy's real
there were several names we heard
Eduardo an Uncle Mike a Quincy Brown
this was someone with a criminal record
what I'm trying to work out with you
here is just the freaking truth Albert
I'm telling you he h gon I was fine okay
well who is He Who tied you up who did
this you didn't do it who did it who
hurt Ganon who has gon they're going to
kill me who is they these are the
questions I need to
know they first told me his name was uo
but it's not it's quiny brown there was
really no connection though I got the
same stories and there was never really
full context to these stories so so
Quincy Brown is the one who has
him he's coming after me I know who he
is quiny brown is the one holding G for
all the money and you didn't tell me so
3 weeks now you've known who has my son
the Dynamics between her and Al were I
think at the very heart of what this
case was about prior to G and going
missing the relationship between her and
Al was deteriorating rapidly in those
phone calls she's constantly talking
talking about and trying to talk alen to
supporting her through this entire thing
she felt like Ganon was the key to draw
Al and closer to her and to keep that
relationship going did you talk to
attorney and F for a divorce I have not
filed anything yet I'll give you the
straight up honest truth where at the
same point now unfortunately 3 weeks
later I was not getting the whole truth
even yesterday when we were talking
wasn't adding up and it still isn't
there's three or four different versions
neither town or investigators are fully
believing leticia's accounts of what
happened to Ganon but coming up next new
information comes to light that may be
the key to solving this whole case he
calls me back and says you're going to
want to come back down here I found the
video and that is what we believe is the
last sighting of
[Music]
him
you know where an 11-year-old is and I
am here telling you we could go find him
and you are not giving us his location
alive or dead I did not hurt my child
okay it's mid-February 2020 officials in
Colorado have been searching for weeks
for a young boy 11-year-old Ganon Stout
while initially reported to police by
ganon's stepmother Leticia Stout she's
been providing several versions of what
happened and they don't seem to be
adding up at one point when speaking to
Al ganon's biological father who's
working with authorities Leticia brings
up another possible player in the case
someone was following us there was this
pregnant lady so I agreed to help the
pregnant lady and I realized she's not
pregnant once she gets in the car I just
was supposed to walk in Petco look
around be normal go drop this lady off
somewhere she told you to walk in who
she forced me it's just being caught up
in the wrong place at the wrong time
with people who are money laundering
wanting me to deliver paper to these
Mexican restaurants and you're supposed
to get packages back from them and I
wouldn't do it you want me to believe
you but I feel like you're just telling
me something to make me feel better
about gandon misson kind of like the
Quincy Brown thing I mean now it's a
pregnant lady with cash in her belly I'm
innocent it took a lot of strength on Al
part to go through those recorded phone
calls he had to keep his cool and not
let her know that the Noose was
tightening that she was quickly becoming
the focal point of the investigation
what is wrong with you what's wrong is
my son's missing and you keep lying to
me okay that's what's wrong again okay
fine give me my son back tell the truth
give me my son back I don't have him
where's he at then ridiculous who has
him you haven't answered not one of my
questions you're not doing nothing but
lying to me and sending me in a
different direction what you know is the
truth but then detectives learn new
information that changes the course of
the whole
investigation one of the first days I
covered this little missing boy the
neighbors were doing whatever they could
and I got to speaking with rodri Drayton
he said you know what I live just a few
doors down and my camera faces their
house he calls me back and says you're
going to want to come back down here I
found the video I found him in the car
with Leticia he was lethargic early on
the morning of the 27th the way he walks
out to the truck clearly showed that he
was under the influence of some sort of
drug and one more thing points to
Leticia Stout evidence is found at the
Stout's home suggesting Ganon was
possibly killed there when Leticia calls
911 the police actually go out to the
scene and walk through the house and
there's nothing immediately apparent
that would suggest something bad had
happened it really goes to the idea that
she did an extensive job of cleaning up
the crime scene and then when we go into
ganon's bedroom you could see very fine
blood staining on the walls so small
that it was hard to see with the naked
eye the investigators they find blood
and DNA all over the home and the most
chilling part of where they find the
blood in his bedroom is it's underneath
his mattress underneath a carpet
underneath the carpet pad and and soaked
into the concrete below and that tells
you how much blood came from this young
child through the blood through the
forensics through the ability to track
her movements in the time frame of when
Ganon was supposedly lost they to piece
together that she had a lot more in
connection to this case than she
initially told law enforcement do you
know why you're here did they inform you
why you under arrest I'm under arrest
yes for what just over a month after
Leticia reported Ganon missing she's
arrested while visiting family in South
Carolina I'm getting charged with what
now we found enough you call it probable
cause okay for a warrant to be issued
okay a warrant for what though it was
for the murder what Mur count and staff
so Theon is murdered that's what the
evidence shows okay she's interviewed
yet again this time by the FBI there's a
lot of stories out there so if someone
truly took Ganon though we need to know
the real story because you put out quite
a few different stories the FBI agent
tells her we heard you telling multiple
stories on the phone without Al and she
says oh I knew you guys were already
recording she says she was hurt he
wasn't trying to work with her so she
purposely gave him multiple different
stories I don't think you intended
at all something bad happened in his
room if you didn't do it and it helps me
find gon I didn't do it okay well then
help me find out who did who did what
that toon in his room to don't what toon
in his room there's a pool of blood in
the corner okay that's ganon's blood
where do you think that I had any
involvement with gon and where did he go
you're the last adult with him you told
a lot of lies he would lead her down a
path and right at the point where she's
going to make a statement that would
potentially incriminate herself she's
conscious enough to know that this is
occurring and then she would then pull
back if you can point me to a different
person then I can help you if you
trusted me to talk to me you would tell
me where Ganon is right now I don't know
where gon is you do if you would have
told police the very first night that he
was taken forcibly everything would have
been different
the agent then confronts Leticia on
something that raised red flags earlier
in the
investigation here I even have what you
entered in your
phone the stuff that you've entered and
deleted like lettu us burning from an
arterial bleed direct pressure not
controlling do what I didn't look this
up somebody did from your phone I don't
like my stepson no I don't like my
stepson should I get a divorce how to
get blood out of sheets out of sheets
mhm her Google searches were massive in
this case how long does it take a body
to decompose face transplants find
people who want to go to jail if you did
something by G could you ever admit what
I didn't do anything bad again right now
you're the last person with Canon I
don't do bad things to people I don't I
don't think you do bad things to people
I don't do bad things to anyone and
didn't do anything bad again why would I
hurt our child at everything in the
world why I have no motive none but
investigators come across a recording
from the night when Stout says Ganon
accidentally caused a fire from a candle
that sheds a chilling light on their
relationship Canon I promise this the
last time I'm going to ask you I'm just
freaked out okay are you sure you didn't
didn't do it on purpose he did it okay
you promise not you promise on purpose
Pinky Promise pinky there was one video
where she was manipulating him on that
Sunday night we're going to have to sell
stuff to fix it okay so we figure out
what we got to sell we can sell the sofa
we can sell whatever cuz we got to get
it fixed so lady don't be mad at us and
kick aside the house
okay you got
it you got it
I'm just worried about my okay sh listen
listen listen listen you hear this
little boy's voice and the fear in his
voice and she recorded him you hear that
recording and it's this little boy I
promised I didn't mean to do it and just
his voice shaking and he's
crying while authorities may know who's
responsible for ganon's disappearance
there's still one major missing piece
Ganon is still nowhere to be found
that's when a case- changing Discovery
is made hundreds of miles away we're
here at the bridge next to scam keny
line and reference the
suitcase it was a heartbreaking day we
got the news that 1300 mil away Bridge
inspectors in Pensacola Florida find
this suitcase and everyone's heart sunk
we're expecting the bridge found that
suitcase down there
decided we'd open it to see if anything
was in it body rolled out along with
what appears to be a comforter
investigators discover Leticia rented a
van and drove 1,300 miles to Florida
with her daughter just days after
ganon's disappearance they were tracking
her there was trackers in that rental
car and the way she was going where she
was going if your kids's missing out of
a town in Colorado Springs why are you
leaving we later found out why Hotel
records right near that bridge from
February 4th that gave us
answers authorities believe Leticia
tossed this suitcase with Ganon dead
inside over a bridge in the middle of
the night while her daughter Harley
slept in a nearby hotel room ganon's
body was just discarded as if it was
trash he suffered from not only stab
wounds but also a gun shot injury the
bullet that was recovered from Ganon was
able to be connected to a gun that was
found in leticia's
bedroom the handgun that was used
actually belonged to alout what was
really eerie about the way that it was
found is that as it was sitting on the
dresser it was actually pointing at a
photograph of Ganon it looks like he was
trying to defend himself and fighting
back but it was a brutal brutal attack
back he was stabbed 17 times he was hit
over the head four times and then the
final injury that he sustained was a
gunshot wound to his jaw he was also
given hydrocodone so he was poisoned by
a very strong drug it really speaks to
the horrific hours of ganon's last hours
here on Earth
alive Leticia is accused of the murder
of 11-year-old Ganon Stout but the
twists in this story are quite over with
yet when we return a roadblock in the
case she felt like she could manipulate
the court system she was trying to Fain
incompetence not a
monster a
[Music]
moner you asked me did I kill game that
hurt it hurt me to ask it cuz you're my
wife wife I'm begging you I want to help
but I can't get trouble for it I do it
and I'm not a criminal I don't kill
people it's March 2020 and investigators
have Leticia stal in custody in South
Carolina they believe she stabbed and
shot her 11-year-old stepson Ganon to
death 2 months earlier in January out in
Colorado letian authorities arried back
in Colorado where she set to stand trial
however now there's even more delays
there was always something on her end to
delay there was letters to the judge
wanting to represent herself changing
her plea she went through at least two
competency hearings and even a third
closer to that trial date competency is
a person's ability to participate in
their defense and to be
tried after more than 3 years in in
April 2023 Leticia Stout goes on trial
for first-degree murder tampering with
the deceased human body and tampering
with evidence as for Stout's defense she
entered a plea of Not Guilty by reason
of insanity January 27 2020 ganon's home
turned into the stuff of nightmares the
one place a little boy like Ganon should
have felt the safest is in fact where he
was brutally murdered evidence in this
case will show that she could
distinguish between right and wrong I
felt very confident going into the trial
but there's that unknown you're bringing
strangers into the courtroom that have
to sit and listen to evidence that's
very difficult to listen to having to
get over the hurdle of proving that she
was sane is an added element there was
an overwhelming amount of evidence the
timelines the locations of the GPS even
the
recordings it did come up during the
trial that Leticia may suffer from
having multiple personalities and from
from an insanity defense standpoint if
your client has any kind of mental
disease or defect you throw that all
against the wall and see what sticks it
was an awful awful thing that was done
to G in the court of public opinion and
the media he's guilty this is going to
come down 10 s the issue for that both
for the defense and ultimately the jury
in making the decision is whether or not
she had that multiple personality
disorder the stal was dealing trauma and
abuse that had been going on since she
was a toddler the troubled
childhood that's where the
fragmentation personality comes in the
big thing that stuck out to me was
leticia's demeanor in the courtroom all
eyes were on her when they're giving the
defenses opening statements that was the
only time I saw any reaction and it was
her putting a tissue
to her face when they were talking about
alleged abuse she went through as a
child nothing about Ganon it's insane go
from teacher loving stepmother loving
mother being a killer of a 11 yearold
boy there was some major psychotic
crack much of the state's case focused
on just that leticia's mental state at
the time of the crime even calling her
daughter to the stand had you ever seen
your mom change personalities into
someone she isn't no had she ever been
treated for any mental illness in your
lifetime no if there was one person that
knew the defendant best it was Harley
hunt her own daughter and having her
come in and talk to the jury and the
manipulation that she suffered at the
defendant's hands went a long ways to
show that she was a very sound mind that
she knew exactly what she had done did
you ever ask your mom what are we doing
why are we leaving no I didn't really
question her a lot I would be told that
I'm being like disrespectful or like
talking back and what would happen if
you were being disrespectful or talking
back to your mom sometimes she would
like backhand me the conscious decision
to drive ganon's body all the way down
to Florida how many times Leticia must
have been able to think through her
actions and and maybe having opportunity
to change course but she didn't I'm
still in shock I defended her for years
and I just feel like manipulated and led
to you could see how hurt the family was
that this was even a argument brought up
that she was insane they knew her for
years and years and she was totally fine
they trusted her to take care of their
kids and now it's just suddenly a
switched argument oh she's insane did
Miss Al ever give you any self diagnosis
of potential mental illnesses that she
felt she had she talked a lot about
being manic slipping in and out of
reality did she ever bring up anything
about having another personality or
multiple personalities she did not she
was reading books and was picking up
things that she could do or say that
would support an insanity defense and
she did those things during different
evaluations she was clearly trying to
manipulate that process did you or Dr
Gray ever consider the fact that she
could just be making this all up yes and
then comes Maria a different personality
of Leticia she talks about going into
protection mode and she often references
Maria as the protector someone who has
this associative identity disorder are
they going to be able to recall what
happens as a different person I would
think that if Miss sta had dissociated
into
Maria there would be a lack of awareness
or understanding or memory the biggest
hurdle I think was really the gravity of
the injuries that Ganon suffered it gave
us some concerns that it wouldn't be too
much of a stretch for a juror to say the
only reason that somebody would carry
out an attack on 11-year-old like that
is if they were crazy that they had gone
insane
that's exactly what the defense argued
not that Leticia didn't commit The
Killing but that she was insane at the
time and not criminally
responsible when I was uh interviewing
her over a period of time suddenly it
seemed to me that she was speaking
Russian someone was in the home we don't
understand someone was in the home it
looked as though she had switched into a
different entity did she describe any
alars to you or other personas she
referred to somebody named Maria Maria
apparently was a a physically abusive
entity and when I first saw that I
thought have I just met the aspect of
her personality that killed Ganon you
don't understand I had to protect the
people go in the house
okay because if someone was in the
homeall they were going to rape someone
they less them did not kill them I had
to protect them all I
did and I fired the I did not know
didn't have a safety I'm train to kill
that's what I do kill her living I took
the gun I fired the gun and
some they had cap look like a man killed
the M did whatever
to I kill the when she was speaking in
that Maria voice that gave me goosebumps
cuz that was the first first time I
think I heard anything of any admission
really of guilt but it's in this other
voice their job is to put doubt in the
juror's minds right and those videos
were certainly
compelling the case is then delivered to
the jury as leticia's future is placed
in their hands to decide when you turn a
case over to a jury for deliberations
you sit there and you think about well
could we have done this differently did
the jury pick up on the things that were
important for the case or did they miss
something were they paying attention you
just never know until you get that
verdict there was that feeling of fear
what could happen but there was just
that hope it would be a result soon and
there would be Justice
served after nearly 8 hours of
deliberations the jury comes back with
their decision we the jury find the
defendant Leticia Stout guilty the jury
found that Leticia Stout was was guilty
of all crimes straight across the board
it was not surprising to me after all of
those lies and all of those calculations
and miscalculations that the jury
thought you weren't insane you knew what
you were doing and this is murder in the
worst possible
way you have shown No Remorse throughout
this process instead you've made a
choice to build a Web of Lies because
you didn't want to face the consequences
your conduct in this case deserves the
maximum punishment I remind you to the
custody of the Colorado Department of
Corrections for the remainder of your
life with no possibility of
parole I remember ganon's Mom telling me
after the verdict and this it it hurt to
hear that she and her heart knows that
Ganon loved this woman in his final
breaths it was just incomprehensible how
someone could hate a little boy who
loves you
the idea that a little boy could suffer
this sort of horrific attack at the
hands of Somebody That was supposed to
be caring for them is unimaginable it's
something that will always be on my mind
but most importantly I'll never forget
the smile that Ganon had the stories of
how happy he was and how much of a
fighter he was and just the love that he
had for his entire
family this is a tough one it really
really is thinking about what happened
to ganet at the hands of a woman who was
supposed to protect him and based on
what we saw with Leticia stal I wouldn't
be so hopeful that we'll ever get the
straight story of what happened now at
the time of this recording we've
actually reached the 4year anniversary
of this young boy's death and to imagine
where his life could have been and what
he would be doing today that to me is
the saddest part thanks for joining us
here on Prime crime I'm Jesse Weber and
as always stay
[Music]
safe